hello there I'm John Oliver
amateur Astro herpetologist as you may
remember two weeks ago vladimir putin
sent a veritable bang bus full of
lizards into space and then quickly lost
touch with it like an old college
roommate well we here at last week
tonight lept into action launching our
now famous hashtag go get those geckos
global awareness campaign people across
the globe united behind our hashtag in a
way they hadn't since the era of hashtag
true detective season 2 and hashtag this
could be us but you playing look look
luminaries in their fields joined the
chorus from fake president Julia Louie
Dreyfus to international businessman
Richard Branson to fake astronaut
Patrick Stewart to actual astronaut Buzz
Aldrin even 12-time WWE Champion Randy
Orton tweeted our message of reptilian
justice which we did not entirely
understand until we realized that Randy
Orton's nickname is the Viper and Vipers
are basically born to go get geckos it's
in their DNA and also are non
professional wrestler view as they
pitched in as well you took to Twitter
and Instagram to spread the word you
emailed the Kremlin directly and
apparently given that their website
didn't crash the Russian government has
better programmers than the FCC that's
that's the good news that is the good
news the even better news is that it
worked
BBC News another news organization that
operates primarily on accent based
authority Howser has you laughed a
little too hard at that Hazar has
verified that Russia has regained
communication with their interstellar
automobile
geckos have been got now I don't want to
take too much credit here especially
since they were apparently rescued
before our show was even broadcast so so
let's just say I feel mostly responsible
for the safety of those cold-blooded
little machines so so please using the
hashtag we got those geckos spread the
word of our triumphs because this is
just the tip of the iceberg people now
that the geckos are okay there's nothing
we can't accomplish as a species we can
usher in a new era of peace on earth we
can dedicate our resources to education
and scientific research we can cool it
with all the gritty reboot of 90s
cartoons we can do all of these things
so thank you viewers Thank You
professional wrestlers Thank You
astronauts both actual and fictional for
making the world a better place unless
unless of course the geckos die before
they get back to earth in which case we
are completely thank you so much
please join us sundays at 11:00 on HBO
for a new mostly lizard free episode of
last week tonight we got the geckos